alors on va parler de tout ça interview
vérité
alors gérard bourgoin vous êtes né en
1939 à auxerre votre père était boucher
votre grand père aussi
et pourtant suite à un accident vous
avez le dégoût du sang parce qu'à l'âge
de 5 ans a été renversée par une
traction avant
conduite par les allemands et depuis
vous avez du mal la viande crue le sand
j'aime beaucoup la viande j'ai pris
beaucoup de viande je n'aime pas trop vu
voilà voilà c'est ça alors à l'école
vous étiez pas très bons en orthographe
du nom mais mais mais mais mais
excellent au calcul l'éjection calcul
vous avez eu votre certificat d'études à
14 ans et ensuite elle poursuivi vous
êtes jusqu'en seconde quand je vous ai
fait un cap2 comptable vous êtes devenu
comme votre père grand père boucher en
commençant par être commis boucher voilà
alors après l'armée l'envoient déjà vous
êtes un mec malin après l'armée vous
fait le tour de tous les patrons
bouchers parisiens et vous proposer de
travailler à l'oeil pour eux et en même
temps vouloir piquer à chacun leurs
meilleures idées pour apprendre ensuite
vous travaillez dans la boucherie
familiale et or l'a toujours assez malin
vous mettez à concocter des recettes que
vous piquer votre mère par exemple à la
ja de lapenche à blida un truc de votre
maman de ça eller et les vendre dans la
région avec une avec une camionnette
petite camionnette une petite de chevaux
et vous savez des choses je vois
travailler s'est fait plaisir c'est ce
qui se passe dans ces cas là
merci bien
alors ça marche oui en 63 vous installé
dans une ancienne ferme
un atelier de découpe de poulets et de
lapins de dindonneau et bientôt vous
êtes président des établissements
bourgoin voilà ça c'est le début de
votre réussissez dans la pintade
voyez les jours vous rencontrez de
caroline c'est bien le cas à part dont
je deviens plus tard ce pas en avant
avant cela monsieur bourgoin jouteurs
monsieur pourquoi pas sur moi c'est pas
ton rien normal
comme on mène enfin comme demi roumaines
ont collé michèle laroque
mais je veux dire qu'elles sont bien les
grossesses dans ce pays bien gérard dont
vous ajoutez les rôtis les escalopes
prédécoupés votre production
et puis l'essor de la grande
distribution fait dresse parce que vous
avez été en france un des inventeurs de
ces petites barquettes qu'on trouve au
rayon en fait ils en mettent les
produits de luxe au service de tout le
monde voilà voilà démocratie déjà alors
type extrêmement entreprenant quand la
vitesse est limitée
vous passez à l'avion puis comme après
les avions s'il vous plaît pas vous nous
apprenez des piloter et puis après vous
avez votre ligne aérienne à vous qui
s'appelle chagnotine rc russe ça mais ça
donne aussi airbus qui est bien et voilà
et en 1981 vous construisez la plus
grande usine d'abattage de poulets et de
volaille et la lecture poulet
voulait
le net
là vous devenez le roi du poulet gérard
bourgoin est votre ambition est de
nourrir les consommateurs mondiaux du
21e siècle
par exemple en 87 vous vendez cent mille
tonnes de poulets au moyen-orient c'est
moi le mariage la cent mille tonnes de
moins jeunes pour lui que moi je suis
posters de lui dans ma charge
c'est vrai c'est vrai ce moniteur
bussard mois martin aussant mille couler
vous revoir et les trois usines on se
cale 5,5 milliards de francs de chiffre
d'affaires pour combien de temps les
arrive à ça très peu de temps finalement
en 20 ans en vad en battant et un en
fait née tout simplement et 35 ans de
travail et 20 24 ans depuis les pluies
touchent quelque chose merci tu as mangé
polluants des stock options bien alors
en 91
c'est moins drôle votre fils se tue en
avion il a comme lui il avait
déverrouiller le marché pub à vous allez
à cuba et c'est comme ça que vous
devenez ami avec fidel castro s'est
s'agir alors ce coup de foudre que vous
avez pour cuba vous le faites partager à
vos amis gérard depardieu
patrick poivre d'arvor pourquoi ce coup
de foudre pour fidel castro qui est
quand même un type est un dictateur qui
met les gens en prison
fidèle c'est un mythe 1 il est
extrêmement intelligent il met toute son
intelligence toute sa finesse au service
de son peuple
j'entendais tout à l'heure qu'on parlait
de l'inégalité entre éventuellement son
traitement et celui de du peuple cubain
y en a pas je peux vous le dire mais j'y
vais chaque trois semaines j'étais
encore à la fin de cette semaine où il y
avait une délégation de sénateurs
français
une quinzaine j'ai par michel charasse
et je crois que ils peuvent en faire le
rapport exact il n'y a pas de bavure ce
niveau là d'accord mais le côté
obscur de la chose ça t'intéresse pas du
tout mais ils bougent pas pendant les
jingles
excusez moi donc gérard bourgoin à vous
vous êtes je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
vous allez tu es le roi du poulet mais
vous êtes plein le napoléon du poulet
est un jour comme napoléon s'est cassé
les dents sur moscou vous casser les
dents sur l'espagne ça a été vraiment un
problème pour vous en 92
vous essayez de racheter une usine en
espagne et à ce moment là vous avez 500
millions de pertes
il toujours que les responsables
d'entreprises doivent prendre des
risques aleris doivent être calculées et
puis de temps en temps et bien il se
laisse peut-être entraîner un petit peu
trop la politique de l'europe qui peut
être même un peu trop vite séduit et
j'ai peut-être eu le tort de vouloir
avoir raison avant les autres puisque
maintenant ça marche bien que j'ai
souffert beaucoup et que je sais pas moi
qui ai souffert mais ceux qui m'ont
succédé et qui ont été amenées
malheureusement déposer les voilà alors
en 94 les banques vous demande de passer
la main et c'est votre fille corinne 27
ans qui prend la direction ait quitté
les coupes sombres dans le budget de
votre entreprise fin du sponsoring auto
fin du sponsoring du football mais rien
n'y fait les banques vous lâche et vous
dites vous même avec beaucoup
d'honnêteté d'ailleurs vous dites j'ai
fait des erreurs très grave
oui je découvre surtout ce qui est et ce
qui a été et ce qui est devenu un grand
succès du cinéma le placard c'est à dire
le changement du regard des autres
on vous regarde et on vous admire parce
que vous êtes puissant parce que vous
êtes considéré comme riche même si vous
êtes riche de dette
et puis là seul coup les regards se
détournent et c'est là qu'on apprend
vraiment à voir ce que sont les hommes
et ce que sont les vrais amis maintenant
t'es dans la merde t'es sympa je suis un
peu plongé la vie privée
pas se permettre un ample est l on vous
dit
alors vous dites justement même quand on
est riche de des et c'est vrai les
causes de la catastrophe c'est ça c'est
des fonds propres
inexistant beaucoup d'emprunts 1 100
millions de frais financiers par an un
peu comme tapis vous avez monté un peu
votre affaire avec l'argent des autres
on peut dire non je crois que si vous
voulez il ya les constructeurs 1 il ya
les récupérateurs d'entreprise 1 j'ai
jamais profité des affaires des autres
j'ai tout créer chez tout con c'est vrai
tout monté et un j'étais très fier
d'être à la tête de 7000 salariés ma
grande fierté aujourd'hui c'est de les
avoir encore très souvent téléphone et
d'avoir beaucoup autour de moi et ils
m'ont beaucoup aidé à passer le moment
difficile il continue à m'aider beaucoup
a possiblement difficile ouais rien en
2000 dépôt de bilan en redressement
judiciaire le groupe est vendu 150
millions de francs il y avait quand même
un milliard de pertes
finalement c'est ce qui me paraît le
plus important c'est de savoir que 90 %
des emplois ont été sauvés et
qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises vivent
on peut dire avec un coefficient de
remplissage total et les maires qui
continuent à voir les entreprises dans
leurs communes sont très fiers de
continuer dans les taxes
professionnelles avant l'escale des
salariés qui chaque matin mon travail
alors vous avez plein de problèmes après
avait été accusé d'abus de biens sociaux
d'escroquerie de faux bilans été mis en
examen
à cause de quoi ce jeu comprend pas
rousset 1 je crois que les banques ont
toujours de beaucoup de mal à digérer
leur père y avait tout misé arrive
beaucoup de sentiments pour prendre un
milliard cent millions intérêts ils en
ont ils ont eu beaucoup de
très peu de pudeur a tenté de vouloir
démontrer qu'il y avait eu détournement
de biens je sais exactement où j'en suis
j'avais dit dès le début que je ne
craignais aucune question du juge je
reste dans la même optique je fais
complètement confiance à la justice
française
d'ailleurs qui me laisse vivre
complètement ma quiétude totale et qui
je dois le dire fait très bien son
travail
oui ce qu'il faut dire si vous avez été
associé dans une affaire de pétrole à
cuba 1 et que vous étiez les riches vous
dirigez toujours cette société vous
n'êtes plus actionnaire je suis pu
actionner en moi je la dirige parce que
votre associé obtenu la saisie
judiciaire de vos parts dans les
associer à les banques
ouais les associés conférait le bénéfice
départ ce sont les banquiers français
ouais vous et ruiné là je te fais et
depardieu a perdu du pognon à faire du
pétrole à cuba non mon chien on ya passé
dix ces actions ravira laisser l'europe
et même jugement les nôtres astérix et
au réveil de lui louer
alors ce qui fut incroyable et vous à
nous expliquer en fait c'est que malgré
tout ça vous êtes quand même élu
président de la ligue nationale de
football
malgré tout ce qui peut être racontée
ici ou là j'ai jamais fait aucune erreur
de gestion j'ai dirigé pendant 25 ans la
jia d'auxerre un club qui est parti de
rien et qui est aujourd'hui où il est
pour l'amener là où aller et je crois
que le moment venu
comme il fallait un libéral la tête du
football on m'a demandé de l'être et
c'est comme justement vous êtes un
libéral êtes partisan de la cotation des
clubs de foot en bourse
je suis surtout partisans si vous voulez
de respecter la loi française la loi
française a imposé aux clubs de football
professionnels de se transformer en
société anonyme
on peut pas d'un côté leur maître
l'obligation qui est liée aux sociétés
anonymes et d'autre part ne pas le
remettre les droits
ces sociétés anonymes et parmi les
droits il ya les moyens de se financer
partout dans le privé dans
l'institutionnel et bien sûr dans les
parcs publics alors cotation des clubs
en bourse fiscalité allégée sans malt
est un libéral propriété indivise
des droits alors évidemment vous en
pensez quoi vous cette prime et attise à
sion du foot et cette libéralisation du
foot j'ai pas tout à fait d'accord je
pense qu'on mélange un peu trop l'argent
et le sport mais bon il ya sans doute
des décisions qui vont être prises dans
un avenir prochain notamment pour faire
payer des droits de retransmission des
événements sportifs notamment radio
ouais ou radio publique très franchement
je suis pas sûr qu'on soit sur la bonne
voie d'abord ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que le droit à l'information ne saurait
et de bafouer qu'il est tout à fait
normal que tout le monde puisse tête
gratuitement informé par la voie des
journalistes de presse de radio de
télévision des résultats des sports de
l'existence d'un match mais à partir du
moment où à travers un spectacle qui est
celui du sport professionnel on crée des
journaux et on fait des journaux avec
des partenaires qui sont des parrains
avec des partenaires qui sont des
publicitaires et je parle ici devant un
grand homme de télévision est le média
j'ai ce que c'est d'acheter des bd qui
sait ce que tu exalter les lois je crois
que ceux qui achètent les lois 2e à
droite et de bafouer donc ce que vous
dites clairement c'est si c'est pour les
résultats bien sûr il ya pas de problème
si c'est pour raconter le match à la
radio ou raconter le match dans un
journal faut payer mais je crois que
tout est clair que vous en pensez quoi
raymond je pense qu'il n'est pas sain
quand même que tout cela soit dominée
par l'argent voilà je comprends qu'un
certain nombre de spectacles
on soit contraint de les payer mais le
sport est quelque chose que les français
aient d'autres attendaient ils ont
besoin je crois de de pouvoir suivre des
matches sans être obligé de passer à la
caisse moi je trouve ça et passeront à
la caisse les gens c'est le patron de la
radio et les moyens d'information
passeront à la caisse et d'une certaine
manière on pourra bien que quelqu'un
paye viendra pas sur le président le
français payent l'impôt est fait pour ça
le français paye ne l'oublié pas les
chaînes publiques soit financée par
l'impôt ou faut pas s'emballer on pousse
jean marie cavada
le patron de radio france est pas
content du tout vous savez ça oh mais
jean-marie à une position totalement
différente lorsqu'il s'exprime dans les
médias seuls que lorsqu'il est avec moi
et qu'on discute de l'avenir justement
de ces fameux droits radio et je peux
vous dire qu'il ya pas d'équivoque là
dessus et guerre monsieur jean marie
cavada sait très bien où il en est et
personnellement je ne sais également
bien alors on va revenir sur vous
aujourd'hui donc vous gagnez 8600 francs
par mois parce que vous avez beaucoup
d'argent qui est saisie à la source
heureusement il ya la ligue nationale de
football vous avez un loyer que pas très
cher 25000 francs par mois qui est payé
par la ligue
une 607 de fonctions plus les frais les
repas voilà mais pour quelqu'un qui
travaille depuis l'âge de 15 ans et dure
comme vous avez travaillé c'est pas
terrible non mais je crois que s'il
voulait après 47 ans de sécurité sociale
je vais avoir droit ma retraite elle
vient d'ailleurs d'être débloquée le
mois dernier parce que non je n'ai pas
droit le retrait pour 69 vous aviez pas
cotisé moment une petite bavure vous
savez j'ai de 57 ans 60 a été alarmé au
moment de l'algérie et il ya eu un petit
trou dans ma carrière qu'on n'arrivait
pas à reconstituer parce que j'ai fait
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure beaucoup
de patrons dans la région parisienne
certains n'avaient peut-être pas tout à
fait les déclarations restent ils
arrivent et je vous rassure je suis pas
venu pour faire le procès la sécurité
sociale les caisses de retraite tout et
ajouterait bien il a fallu qu'il a fallu
quatorze mois mais tout est assez mal
avec le blé qui la veille dans la bien
planqué un petit peu repas nous prendre
pour des cons comme un mot la dgi
on l'a dit on l'a dit on l'a dit on l'a
dit vous le savez généraux lundi xavier
planty du pognon au canada belga par la
landi alors en les prenant pour des cons
une image une image pour terminer vous
vous souvenez vous aviez une baraque
sublime et dans cette barre à xavier
fait creuser à l'inter de la baraque une
piscine est à côté de la piscine xavier
mis un bio de boucher pour montrer à
tous vos invités
d'où vous veniez vous êtes toujours la
piscine dans la piscine j'ai pu mais
chez touche sur le billot
monsieur
combas lamy